-A lot of fans are theorizing
that this Friday
Taylor Swift is going to drop
"1989 (Taylor's version),"
and could also release --
[ Cheering ]
could also release
"Speak Now (Taylor's Version)"
on the same day.
-Yeah, but how do you know that?
Isn't that just a rumor?
-[ Scoffs ] The clues are
everywhere, Tariq.
-What clues?
-Okay, so in Taylor's last music
video for the "Red" --
for Red (Taylor's Version)"
bonus track
"I Bet You Think It's About Me,"
there's a wedding cake.
And on the cake there are
numbers 13 and 26.
You follow?
-Yeah, no.
-Uh, "Red (Taylor's version)"
was Taylor's most
recent re-release.
13 is Taylor's favorite number,
and this Friday, May 13th
is 26 weeks
from the release date
of "Red (Taylor's version)."
-Okay, well, I guess --
-Also if you look at Taylor's
official store,
signed CD copies of
"Fearless (Taylor's version)"
are currently on sale
for $19.89.
Get it?
1989, 1989!
-Alright.
Well, then you're probably --
-But also,
"Red (Taylor's version)"
was listed on sale
on her store for $20.10
in purple text.
-And that means what?
-Are you even listening?
The original "Speak Now"
was released in 2010,
and the cover of that album,
she's wearing a purple dress.
Purple, 2010, $20.10!
[ Laughter ]
And six days ago, after dropping
her newest single,
"This Love (Taylor's version),"
which is a song originally
from "1989," she wrote
on Instagram that she
"reliving the '1989' tour."
But she also put a bunch
of merch called
"The old Taylor Collection"
that features clothes
referencing both "1989"
and "Speak Now."
I mean, it can't be
any more obvious.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You --
You know you're 47 years old,
right?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but I'm 47,
Jimmy's version.